right now with this whole thing we have
on college campuses with social justice
warriors and safe rooms and trigger
warnings yes the things we've talked
about you wrote an interesting piece
about this on your Facebook page that
was related to comedy and all of this
and a little bit it was sort of about
your dad but it jumped off because of
Jerry Seinfeld making a comment yeah and
taught and Todd glass had written a
reply to a piece in the LA Times and he
felt you know he was kind of on the
other side of it of respecting people's
you know rights to define themselves
more and you know and I just I just kind
of I'd finally after I think you know
about a year and a half or two years of
trying to think about all this had
pulled all my thoughts together yeah and
and and then some of it I've already
shared here but the whole trigger
warning thing I mean I really would have
loved my dad to unpack the just the
phrase trigger joy all right just to
help us unpack it a little bit and only
imagine who he would have pissed off
with that I'm sure it would have been
the feminists considered himself a
feminine right I mean you know that was
the irony right so something like that
he would have pissed off the feminists
he was very Pro woman actually yeah he
did was to empower women and ever he
would really talk about something yeah
his humor for the most part I would say
is very Pro woman and but I mean even
when he talked about using the term rape
you know and it can rape ever be funny
and then he tells this joke about you
know Donald or Daffy Duck [ __ ] Elmer
Fudd or something
it's funny it's funny it's a great but
well yeah so that's gauge duck rape I'm
sorry it's pretty funny now I've got the
vegans yeah you've got every oh man and
the game all right please trigger
warning on that that joke right there
please yeah so yeah I would yeah I yeah
I do like you I miss him too there are
certain things that come up where I
where I do I'm like I wish dad was here
and then I'm like okay so we're gonna
have to figure this out on my own like
or on our own like without dad how to
walk through this you know and there's
some comics out there who I think
definitely help with this absolutely
work is helping I was gonna ask you that
a little closer
but as long as i think bill maher is i
think lewis black is I think louis c.k
is doing brilliant work I think Amy
Schumer is doing great work yeah Nora
done just went after her today and
because she's talking about using naming
her body parts using nasty words to name
her body parts and she thinks it's self
shaming so that's gonna be an
interesting conversation between the
feminists what's going on with that and
you know and I and there's a ton of
younger comics too that are doing great
work and not that Amy Schumer isn't but
yeah I mean there's there's there's good
work going on it there Chris Rock you
know always does great work yeah so you
know they're out there pushing pushing
pushing the edge line they should be so
last thought on the free speech and the
political correctness stuff is is this
where we could really teach younger
people and I hate to say that as if yeah
I mean if there's an arrogance in that
too I mean I think generations come up
and they've got their own worldview
they've got their own life experience
they're trying to define themselves but
yes I think they weren't around for the
fights they weren't around for Lenny
Bruce getting arrest right they weren't
around for my dad getting arrested they
don't understand the luxury they have
around free speech and this regressive
left I guess that's what we're calling
them now I had I saw one of your bets
when I'm calling these people that would
be attacking your dad
yeah and it's there's an
authoritarianism around it there's a
need to control everything in order for
the world to be comfortable and hey you
know what I get it that generation is
facing a planet that's dying an economy
that doesn't look very good politics
that have stopped working our democracy
is stopped working yeah I too would want
to control things and so maybe if you
can control people's language and create
a sense of safety I mean maybe that's
what this is about
psychological level I don't know I get
it but yeah I think it is our job to at
least bring some history up and educate
them about the fights we've had in this
country too and to understand what the
the purpose of free speech is and it's
not like and our government is no longer
censoring yes this is corporate America
and these interest groups yeah you know
did you ever think or someone so your
father literally arrested by it because
of exercising his free speech yeah right
this is someone who lost gigs because of
using pretty mundane curse words do you
think he could have ever imagined if he
would agree with what you just said that
you would fear the lack of free speech
not because the government is coming
yeah which is sometimes we're doing it
to ourselves
yeah do you think he could have ever
envisioned envision I don't know I mean
he had a lot to say about business and
corporate corporations I mean he really
bet he hated all them they are they are
the owners of this country and have been
you know the Industrial Age began was
that bit in his last HBO special about
the true owners yeah yeah but yeah I
mean he would have a lot to say about
that and he I mean it's not like you
know ten years ago corporations weren't
trying to shave I mean advertising
dollars shape everything on television I
mean now with the internet it's
interesting because we have a lot more
freedom you know and and you know and I
look at like the bigger picture but EMU
think of like the expansion of the
freedom that the Internet's given us so
it's not strange that some other part of
our culture wants to shut something down
you know there's this there it is a
balance like this all the time you know
whether it's in our own individual
psyches or the collective psyche so it's
fascinating and ultimately you know what
I tell people when people say oh you're
dad I wish you know and I'm like yes I
get it but it's true and I know but I
remind people I say look no matter what
we can remember this dad said when
you're born you get a ticket to the
Freak Show
and when you're born in America you get
a front-row seat so we are at the Freak
Show and then he added later on another
thing which I love which is and some of
us
get to sit on the side and take notes
and talk about it which is what we get
to do yeah so you know which is a really
privileged position to be in but now
everyone gets that privilege ition
because it's the internet and there's
comments
yeah we've cultivated something nice